need to get married before Dutch law
before you can get married at the Moroccan consulate
you must be married for Dutch law
and I'm going to tell you how to do that
the first thing you do
is choosing a municipality where you want to get married
in this situation you are not bound to the municipality
where you are registered
on Monday or Tuesday morning
that differs per municipality
you have the opportunity to get married for free
this is without an extensive ceremony
do you want to use this option
keep in mind that the town halls
and mainly the town hall in large cities
on these days
have long wait times marry you one day
what you have to pay for
then the costs will be between 600 and €1,000
these prices also differ per municipality
the second thing you do
is to report to the selected municipality
that you want to get married
this is what you call notification for marriage taken
you can do this at the counter of the municipality
or easily online via the website
if you do this online
you will also see an overview of all documents
that you must submit
in addition,
you must register at least two witnesses
as soon as your report is approved
you can choose a wedding date
and the date must then take place within a year
as a bridal couple you also have to make another choice
important choice too
and that is what you want in the community
of property marry or not
marrying that community of property means that
from the moment you are officially married
if you go into debt or if you buy things
so the possessions you have
from that moment on is yours both
should the marriage end until the divorce
then everything is fifty fifty example
let's say you during your marriage
have accrued a debt of €10,000
that means your future ex partner
is responsible for half of that debt
it can also be done differently
imagine you have saved thirty thousand euros
during your marriage
then your
future ex partner entitled to fifteen thousand euros
so half of it
you do not want to marry in community of property
then you must record this at the notary
this was all you needed to know about getting married
for Dutch law
you need this information in a moment
then make sure to save this video
until the next video